hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be a video all about how Jon Snow is
related to the White Walkers and the
night King on a TV show so just careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on the show so far there are a
couple key ideas and understanding the
differences between the show and the
books the night King on the TV show is a
little bit different from the character
in the book so I'll try to explain those
backstories a little bit as well there
is a new round of the game of Thrones
giveaway is for one of the enhanced
editions of the books all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so that you
don't miss anything a lot of you have
asked about the history of the night
King on the TV show because a lot of
book readers have known about the
night's king from old man's tales for a
long time so a lot of the lower of Game
of Thrones is told orally through other
characters like old man to tell legends
of people like the 13th Lord Commander
of the Nights Watch who became the first
night's king the legend his old man
tells it is that that Lord Commander was
a stark of Winterfell brother to the
king of winter at the time remember how
the TV show compresses things though so
you have to imagine that there have been
many many White Walkers that have been
sacrificed as children in the books that
have also probably been many Knights
Kings to have taken up the mantle of a
leader of the White Walkers there has to
be someone to create other White Walkers
although they haven't implied any real
organizational structure yet so this
13th Lord Commander that nan says was
the first night's
King was probably just at that time the
newest leader of the White Walkers but
there was also probably one to precede
him the way they explained the tale is
actually pretty fantastic they make it
sound like not long after the creation
of the wall the 13th floor commander
this mythical start fell in love with a
woman north of the wall with skin as
white as the moon in eyes like blue
stars so she herself may have been a
white Walker
the way they describe them in the books
is having this otherworldly beauty the
TV show has made them pretty ugly and
fearsome so there's a lot more plausible
that someone would fall
in love with a beautiful looking white
Walker rather than someone that looked
like this when they consummated their
relationship he himself became a white
Walker they returned to the Nightfort
which is not Castle black it's one of
the other forts along the wall they
ruled there for thirteen years till an
alliance of Brandon the breaker one of
the further kings of winter Yurman King
beyond the wall at the time joined
forces to defeat him so presumably after
that if you believe the legend in what
George R Martin has told us through old
man's tales after that nights King died
another leader of the white walkers was
selected and created so there's this
nice symmetry with the way there are
lowered commanders of the Nights Watch
when one dies another one is anointed
the same thing happening with the White
Walkers as well but the difference in
the TV show is that there's only been
this one night King they implied that he
was the one that we saw in the flashback
that we still see today the way brand
refers to him is that it's the same
person this whole time and he's lived
for some odd thousand years now this is
the time of the First Men when there
were still kings of winter like you
could call Jon Snow king of winter king
in the north but you have to remember
that before the Andals invaded which is
about six thousand years ago in the
books the first men reigned there were
still kings in different regions so you
have people like land the clever who
started House Lannister you have Brandon
the Builder who helped build the wall
also found House Stark during the Age of
Heroes so we're talking upwards of
10,000 years ago in the books the TV
show has compressed that timeline so
that it was about a thousand years ago
so the way George R Martin tells it is
that his mythical night's king is a
legendary figure that's no more likely
to have survived to present-day than
land the clever or Brandon the Builder
so another a lot of conspiracy theorists
they're like what if bran is Brandon the
Builder because of his time-traveling
abilities everything that George our
Martin has implied is that those
mythical ancient figures really did
exist thousands of years ago in as
powerful as brands magic is there's no
big twist beyond the stuff that you've
seen so far I mean there are some
hours that he has you haven't seen but
it's not like he went back to help build
the wall the TV show changes a lot of
things they could take a few liberties
with that they implied the people in the
past like young Ned Stark at the Tower
of joy can hear when brand calls out but
they're purposely very ambiguous about
that that they never have to answer that
question outright
but even though TV show night King is
different from George RR Martin's nights
King the lead character explains to
Brant
how they created the White Walkers after
he has the vision of the first men being
turned into the night king she explains
that they had to create something to get
rid of the first men he was about twelve
thousand years ago after the first men
invaded Westeros they had this big war
with the current inhabitants the
children of the forest who lived way
further south and they do now they
signed a pact with the first men on the
Isle of faces to end the war which is
actually this island right here is one
of the few places left in the south that
has weirwoods that's why they called the
Isle of faces because of the faces on
the weirwoods all of House Stark
descends from the first men so it makes
sense that someone from the north up
near this location here this is in the
very far north where brain is seeing
this tree probably not too far from the
blood ravens tree like you remember the
night king made that ornate formation
with all the heads of the dead horses
and the men near the fist of the first
men so a lot of white Walker children of
the forest history is localized to the
north because that's where they went
after the pact of the first men so it
makes sense on a practical level that
the Starks share blood with this first
men who became the night king of the TV
show but also from a somatic perspective
where you have him tied to Jon Snow who
is the Song of Ice and Fire himself the
whole idea is about the narrative a
balance so wouldn't it be that much more
meaningful if the thing that you were
fighting the evil thing shared some
blood with you shared some common
genetic material so it makes sense that
the Starks share DNA with this night
king now when you talk about the ancient
thirteenth Lords commander night king
even if old man is embellishing about
the dates about how big figures were and
about how events went down there are
still a lot of star
going back thousands of years they
joined the Nights Watch there were
others that previously became Lords
commander when Jon Snow is named Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch he is
almost the thousandth Lord Commander so
I would choose to believe old man even
though a lot of legends do get
embellished there is common DNA between
this night king even some of the White
Walkers which are actually mostly
Craster's sons on the TV show right now
it's just because a lot of the surviving
DNA of the first men lives on in the
peoples of the north most of the people
south of the wall descend from the
Andals although there was the war
between the Andals and the first men so
there was likely some inter marring
between those peoples but for the most
part the blood of the first men as you
would call it lives on in the people of
the north as well as the free folk north
of the wall and then the people wait
further than that the sense that also
share the blood of the first men so
Craster free folk just shares blood of
the first men share some DNA in common
with the Starks of Winterfell so that
means that the White Walkers here are
all related to Jon Snow in some way
Kings blood is something different
though it's important to Melisandre
there might also be important to the
creation of new Knights kings and until
George R Martin tells us otherwise you
have to assume that the knight King is
created in the same way that we saw it
happen on the TV show dragonglass
plunged into the heart of a First Men
now they don't explain whether or not
the blood of the first men is important
in this but there's some more magical
components that they haven't explained
yet like if you stab someone with a
dragonglass dagger in the heart they
would probably just die so there's a
whole bunch of magic that the TV show
has not explained yet but we don't fully
understand what's going on with the red
god we just know about the things that
Melisandre has been able to do the other
things that the red priests and the
books have been able to do this is all
stuff that George R Martin will spell
out in a much greater detail in the
books so if you're new to the books
that's why it's really important to read
those things but don't worry that's also
what I make videos for us to explain
this really cool stuff but hopefully
that explains a little about why it's
important that the Starks share some DNA
with this knight King on the TV show
just because of the Prok
the effective when he was created and
when the first men settled in that area
and created House Stark and when the
wall was built please leave all your
requests for future Game of Thrones
videos in the comments below I'll have
another one posting later this week I'll
be updating my video schedule on the
about page of my youtube channel
congratulations to the new Game of
Thrones giveaway winner Seth Nicholson
please private message be on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a game of Thrones video tonight there'll
be some new Justice League aquaman
behind the scenes stuff posting well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here to learn about the brand-new
Targaryen book the George R Martin is
publishing at the end of the year and
you can click here for my Arya Stark
season 7 predictions thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you in the next video
you